[Music]
hey folks
welcome i am dr brett weinstein this is
dr heather heing and we
are we are the official dart
the first live stream i don't even need
you to confirm that number because i
know it to be correct
you don't need me to confirm it nope
nope it's it's it's dead certain it's
the 91st
it is and i'm glad you're on it because
uh my
grip on time and the passage thereof
seems to be slipping somewhat i think i
said
uh years at some point in last episode
when i meant uh
either days or weeks i didn't remember
what the error was there was another
error and in
uh tweeting out the announcement of
today's show i suggested that it was
going to be on july 7th so
you know hope springs eternal i guess
for that endless summer but we're not
going to get it
yeah the more the more time passes the
lesson i'm a believer in it
no no that's not true actually
well it might be we'll have to sort that
out later when we have a bit more uh
room for that sort of thing all right so
uh today we are going to be
talking about um
ways in which uh we might take control
of our own health
uh with some some sort of personal
personal stories
uh and uh and just a reference again
to the comorbidities that put you a
particular risk
of of i think contracting but definitely
of
falling very ill from kovid
a paper that we have referenced before
and that um
others have as well uh we are going to
talk about
chapter eight from our forthcoming book
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century which is the chapter on
parenthood and relationship
and then we're going to talk a little
bit about um
how parenting might be evolving i'll
just leave it at that that's a that's a
teaser that is somewhat misleading that
sounds uh
awesome maybe maybe
um so if you're watching on just
announcements for the top of the show if
you're watching on youtube consider
switching to odyssey this time we have
in part in order to encourage that and
also to give our moderators a break so
they don't have to be moderating
in two different places we've turned off
chat on uh youtube so if you want to be
involved if you're listening live right
now you want to be on chat um
you should go over to odyssey uh as of
a couple of weeks ago if you are
interested in asking a question for us
to consider
answering in our q a which will follow
this live stream
go to darkhorsesubmissions
and you can ask questions there there
are facts to answer your questions
if you find that you have questions
about
logistics that are not answered there
you can email darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com with any such questions
consider joining one or both of our
patreons
many have of late and we are very
appreciative and you had one of your
conversations your patreon conversations
this morning you have another one
tomorrow great um
you can get uh dark horse t-shirts and
goliath t-shirts and such at
darkhorsepodcast at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and consider joining me in my new
endeavor natural selections my
my newsletter
naturalselections.substance.com
where all the writing is free and if you
subscribe you get a
weekly email to your inbox telling you
what new post has dropped it still has
that new
newsletter smell it it does i'm trying
to get rid of it
it's actually it's all right it's all
yeah okay that's probably not good for
you
no certainly not all right no certainly
not um and so today we do have two
sponsors of the episode without further
ado we will go
into those
all right we've got a new one this week
from mud water mud wtr
mud water is a coffee alternative with
four adaptogenic mushrooms and ayurvedic
herbs
with a seventh the caffeine of a cup of
coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of
coffee each ingredient was added by the
makers of mud water for a purpose
it's got cacao and chai from mood and a
micro dose of caffeine
lion's mane for alertness cordyceps to
help support physical performance
chaga and rishi reishi i pronounce that
to support your immune system turmeric
for soreness cinnamon for antioxidants
so that's what i was told to say i'll
just say this
i enjoy my coffee just fine but i don't
need it and that's intentional
i've spent time places where coffee was
not or might not be available so it's
important to me not to lose
functionality when i don't have it
so i wasn't sure that i needed or wanted
this product and we've been
we've been pitched and have tried a
number of products to advertise on the
show that we have not
accepted because they just didn't seem
right for us they weren't a fit for
our understanding of how to live the
best life with an understanding of your
evolution
but i've now been drinking what mud
water on and off for a couple of weeks
now several weeks actually and
i kind of love it i'm a sucker for
chocolate and there's definitely a hint
of chocolate in there same for their
masala chai blend which has cinnamon and
turmeric
ginger cardamom black pepper nutmeg and
cloves
and i also looked into a lion's mane
which is becoming pretty popular
and often the things that become popular
is just because someone discovered that
you know another culture has been doing
something for a long time and it works
this is one of the mushroom species that
they include and i admit that i'm
intrigued
i found a 2015 paper a research paper
which was
seeking to basically consolidate what is
understood
about about it and the abstract says in
part the described anti-inflammatory
antioxidant
oxidative i'll start over the described
anti-inflammatory
anti-oxidative and immunostimulating
properties in cells animals and humans
seems to be responsible for the multiple
health-promoting properties
so i drink my mud water with a little
bit of their sweetener which is a
mixture of coconut sugar and leukema
which is an andean fruit
and either a bit of cream or sometimes
an alternative milk and i
really really enjoy it and it's got all
the things that you might expect from
such a product it's 100 usda organic
non-gmo gluten free
vegan kosher certified probably on and
on and on
so visit mudwater.com darkhorse to
support the show and use darkhorse at
checkout for five dollars off that's
m u d w t r
dot com slash dark horse use dark horse
at checkout for five dollars off
all right next up is expressvpn and
let's just face the paradox
up front you know that you need a vpn
but you don't know exactly what a vpn
is but that's not so strange the fact is
it's a very technical landscape
a vpn is a protocol that allows you to
anonymize your browsing so that it is
not
documented by someone because we all
know that as we are browsing
online information about what it is that
we are looking at is being collected and
sold
to advertisers and you don't want that
so you're going to need a vpn
and we recommend expressvpn we have
found it to be excellent
many regarded as the best vpn on the
market and for good reason
one excellent reason to use it is that
expressvpn does not log your
activity online many other vpns
especially
cheap ones or free ones log your
activity and
they sell your information to
advertisers and you certainly don't want
that so expressvpn does not log your
activity
their speed is excellent they have
servers all over the world and allow you
to
place your browsing locale anywhere you
want to be for example if you want to be
browsing
in britain so that you can see bbc that
is something you can do with expressvpn
that is something i do very useful it's
easy to use you don't need technical
skills you just install it and then you
hit a single button and voila
you're online using expressvpn
anonymized even to your isp
and it's not just me saying this cnet
and the verge and many other technical
journals rate expressvpn
number one in the world so protect yours
protect yourself with the vpn that i use
and trust
use this link expressvpn.com
darkhorse today and get an extra three
months free
on a one year package that's
expressvpnexpress
darkhorse and visit that link
to learn more all right and in homage
[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by the
number 91 and the letter o
so the o section of the index from
hunter gatherer's guide to
the uh 21st century is short it's much
shorter than
than most of the letters in the index
and it reads
as follows obsession octopuses
olfaction explosive gas is another
dangerous substance and
remapping of olfactory perception
warning provided by
olives omega principle one night stand
strategy opioids opportunity cost
orangutans orcas organelles
osteothes ovid or is it ovid
it's ovid i think i think it's ominous
ovulation concealment of
and oxytocin
this episode brought to you by the
number 91 and the letter o
the letter o all right so
it's odd sound um
we wanted to talk you you specifically
wanted to talk a little bit about
what some some of what you're planning
for
us specifically you and our children um
as the summer uh looks like it might not
in fact be endless but
first let us review briefly
um the fact that people with
comorbidities
um are far more likely to get sick and
die than those without
um of sorts of covet 19
caused of course by stars kobe 2. and
that you know that line that i just read
is
directly from our driving stars kovi 2
extinct post that we made a couple of
weeks ago that we've talked about here
and uh the evidence for that is
is all over the place really um
but one of the papers that uh does a
remarkable job
of uh of kind of collating the evidence
that exists
is the one that we cited in that paper
and also described
at some length by chris martinson um
of peak prosperity uh in which he dove
into this paper a bit more
for a fair bit for 35 minutes or so so
we'll post the link to
martinson's video as well um and i'll
just if you would put this up for a
moment zach
um this original research oh i have you
can't put this up because i
am not playing up with this he cannot
put
yeah god nothing nothing is working very
well
okay um so don't put it up yet because
i've gone back to my notes here
yep which means my computer has gone
dark oh no
yes um here we are
okay so um what
oh boy my new computer arrived yesterday
but but i'm not i'm not on it yet so i'm
i'm really hoping that by this time next
week
uh i have a computer that is far more
functional all right so you can show my
screen now here zach
um this is and i think i think i've
mentioned
uh this paper by name before and then i
also couldn't pronounce
uh the first author's first name
components perhaps
um published in preventing chronic
disease
on the cdc site uh or yeah it's not even
clear to me exactly
um if it's just on the cdc site or if
it's in
a um yeah i guess it is in this
preventing chronic disease
uh journal so the title is underlying
medical conditions and severe illness
among 540
667 adults hospitalized with covert 19
march 2020 through march 2021 and
uh the upshot is really as we have said
uh multiple times you are much more
likely to get sick and to have a and
also separately uh to have a very bad
outcome from kovid if you have one or
more
comorbidities and but it's not just any
comorbidities
and specifically the one that they've
found uh being the most predictive of
bad outcomes is obesity
and and then you know interestingly
anxiety
um and anxiety disorders is number two
and
uh neither the authors in the paper nor
chris martinson talking about it nor
some of his commenters were suggesting
interesting things
um you know nor i
have you know have anything definitive
to say about that like what might that
be one possibility
is that the anxiety actually comes
afterwards um right that at the point
that you're hospitalized
uh for covid then um you were easily
diagnosable with
with anxiety so there's a cause and
effect issue um
and then there's also a possibility that
um because
people with a lot of health problems
tend to present as anxious or depressed
um because of course they would be and
there would be good reason for them to
be
that they would then be diagnosed you
know before ever having covered
be diagnosed as anxious and depressed um
and be given
um you know the anti-anxiety or
anti-depression drugs as a result
and that being on one of those things is
enough to get you described as
being anxious or depressed in such a
study and
some of those drugs may um also be uh
risk factors
uh for for covet as well um although of
course there's one
um that may actually run in the other
direction
right yep exactly um but the you know
the fact that you may be like
more likely to get prescribed such
things if you already have a suite of
other health problems
because you may have good reason to have
anxiety
may mean that this isn't what it seems
and it's actually about
the presence of a bunch of other
underlying health conditions
unclear um but uh but you know the other
the other
predictive comorbidities are you know as
as you might expect things like chronic
kidney disease
and you know as i said the number one uh
the number one
factor um that they found in this over
half a million people is
obesity and so as we've said you know in
service of this
why does almost none of the health
messaging around sorry scoby2
and kovid seem to be
about those things that you can actually
take control of yourself
there is so much that we can do with
diet to
make us healthier and to bring bring
into alignment with expected
um healthy numbers are you know things
like our
our blood sugar and our blood pressure
and things like this
and obviously the more fit you are the
more active you are
uh the less likely you are to be obese
and have other underlying health
conditions
and the downside of getting your health
in order
is not a downside at all right so even
if these things turned out to be
you know third correlates of something
else and they didn't have direct effects
on covid you would almost certainly have
greater longevity greater happiness etc
um for having addressed these things
even if it didn't turn out to have
effects on covid which it seems clear
that it would
um it clearly would on other things you
know metabolic syndrome
is you know this this scourge uh
among americans now and you know it's
not
in non-weird countries this is something
about the modern
the modern lifestyle which includes crap
food and sedentary
um sedentary lifestyles yeah um
and so i was uh in my conversation uh
with um patreon subscribers this morning
i was describing
uh that effectively we have a herd of
elephants in the room
and this is one of them the complete
failure to highlight all of the easy
things to do
that don't appear to have a downside
that do appear to contribute to your
resistance
to coven and it's it's a very strange
reaction because
on the one hand we are literally at the
point of
you know strong-arming people
into certain treatments as we are
ignoring other treatments and it's not
like all of the other treatments are
controversial
right the fact is vitamin d is
spectacularly important as you and i
had talked about early in our our series
on covid
we talked about extensively the evidence
that vitamin d
uh is a strong contributor and you know
the way this works probably
if you have sufficient vitamin d there's
no benefit to extra vitamin d as far as
we know
but the cost of being deficient in
vitamin d is
very very high with respect to
contracting cobit i was um actually
surprised at how strong the evidence has
grown since the last time
i looked at it and with regard to
vitamin d in particular vitamin d in
particular and i guess
the the reason that this is conspicuous
is that we are
not highlighting either the fact that
time spent outside in the sun is
particularly important in
doing away with a deficiency of vitamin
d
that the clock is ticking for those of
us in the northern hemisphere
because yes winter is coming i know
you're shaking your head
you're literally shaking your head but i
tried to make it july today
but nonetheless um this is an obvious
intervention
with no downside tremendous upside
extremely inexpensive something people
can do
you know without needing to radically
alter their lifestyles and yet for some
reason
we are not recommending and so in this
case you're talking about um taking it
sort of
prophylactically but really on an
ongoing basis
well i would i would just tell you how
i'm looking at this for myself
and for our family which is i suspect
but do not know
that building up vitamin d the most
natural way which is
with sunlight has some holdover effect
into winter there's probably some period
of time at which you've had little
enough sun exposure
that you're likely to be deficient
unless you supplement and so
supplementing is
sure to be second best but nonetheless
i'm supplementing go to some place with
sun for a week or go just if you
if you if you have the capacity and the
luxury and yes
right and if you you know there's also
other things you can do it's not like
the sun doesn't shine
uh in the winter in most places it does
and the problem is that you're dressed
up in such a way that you don't
encounter but you can
you can adjust this to an extent and i
and i think and i actually would have to
go back and re-familiarize myself with
the with the research but
um because the winter sun especially the
farther from the equator you are
the winter sun which is you know
december through march in the northern
hemisphere and
june through september and the southern
hemisphere is at such a low
angle and therefore coming through so
much more atmosphere
that it takes much more exposure to get
what you need and then
add to that the fact that you're much
less of your skin is exposed
there's far far fewer hours in the day
when you could possibly be exposed
then it's just actually much harder and
this is you know this is part of why for
instance
uh boy which scandinavians uh the
vikings i guess
who you know famously ate god and they
were not the ones
you know they were the ones who didn't
get rickets and no they didn't know
right what the mechanism of action was
and it turns out you don't need to know
the mechanism of action
for it to be a mechanism of action that
works right in fact we've only
recently been aware of mechanisms of
action at this level at all
right the ability to detect them is hard
enough
um but it certainly seems
you know i think there's a very terrible
argument to be made
about um you know obesity for example
and that there's some
you know they don't want to fat shame
people and so they're not highlighting
that i think that's an absolutely
appalling justification for not
highlighting it
because for one thing if this motivated
people to get uh healthier and to
control
their weight it would have you know
collateral health benefits but you can't
even make that argument with vitamin d
and yeah um and from the point of view
of
you know this is psychologically
stressful for all of us as you point out
there
may well be a tie-in with anxiety that
it may be
a comorbidity and that therefore
making you know making hay while the sun
shines getting out
doing activities that you can do easily
when it's not
cold uh outside is good for you it
allows you to socialize in a way that
isn't
at least so far as we know at this point
risky with respect
to covet all of these things are
pointing in the same direction and so
our failure to highlight all of the
simple
interventions that you can make that do
seem to work that have collateral
benefits like
you know calming you down improving your
mental health
um allowing you to socialize without uh
putting yourself or others
in jeopardy all of these things point in
the same direction and yet they are
conspicuously
absent from the advice right the advice
is
so narrowly targeted as to be suspicious
that's right yeah
which so i i will say
i heard joe rogan uh joe rogan was
trending
last night and this morning um as a
result of people being dismayed at
things he had
said on his podcast of course and as is
so frequently the case when you go and
check
a joe is not did not say the things that
he is reported to have said
and b the things that people imagine
were so upsetting shouldn't have been
upsetting to them one of the things that
joe
said was something very much like what
you and i have been planning to say here
about
these other interventions and the fact
that it's weird that we're not
recommending them um but the thing joe
got in trouble for
most um precipitously was
he was claimed he it was argued that he
said on this podcast that um
the vaccines might be causing mutations
in the virus right which is an odd thing
for him to have said
and when you go and look at what he
actually said he never said anything of
the sort in fact what he did
was he read a he read from a paper
that argued that the vaccines might
select
for mutants that would be more dangerous
or more
transmissible which is a totally
defensible
and highly logical thing for him to have
said so in any case there's some weird
phenomenon where
uh the simple fact of you know joe rogan
speaking common sense is so dangerous
that he needs to be strong manned online
and he needs to trend for
you know supposed villainy um when in
fact what he's saying
are things that should be obvious to
anyone you know there clearly is a
hazard
that comes from the selective
environment that we are creating for
this virus there clearly
is a lost opportunity in not
recommending to people that hey there
are certain things that are under your
control
that you're maybe not doing and you
don't realize may be playing a very
large role in whether or not you're
vulnerable
to covid come january right so
there's some there's some failure of our
discussion that's so fundamental
um that we're just we're missing
opportunities that are obviously there
and should be completely uncontroversial
right indeed which i guess leads then to
the
the question of what we are what we are
doing yeah we can either we can go there
or
given that you segwayed there first
there's a couple other things that
you know as you like either way
all right after you well we're just
going to kind of be all over the place
today
um i guess two things and one i forgot
to mention to you before
um i listened to this uh extraordinary
podcast um
from barry weiss this this week her new
relatively new podcast honestly is
really terrific
and um this week she had camille foster
our friend camille foster who's one of
the hosts of the fifth column podcast
also an excellent podcast
and it's mostly it's camille foster
who has basically chased down the story
of the central park dog walker
uh a woman named amy cooper who got into
an encounter with a guy named christian
cooper no relationship between them
um and as i did not know this until
listening to this
hour-plus conversation apparently that
incident happened within hours of george
floyd's death
that that was that was right it was
actually before
it was just it was like i don't i don't
remember what it was like 12 hours or
something before
and so it just got wrapped up into the
whole the whole
story of um of
you know historic and systemic racism
against black men and how it manifests
today
and um camille foster uh
you know finds amy cooper who's gone
into hiding who's
nowhere that anyone can find her at this
point and talks to her and he does due
diligence and he does journalism
and he finds that the story is not what
we were told
right it's just it's it's not what it
was told it's not a and i refuse to even
use the epithet you know they're
calling her karen i you know i as i've
said before i
hate the idea and this is another kind
of other ring of dehumanizing people the
idea
that uh you know middle-aged white women
who
are you know too nosy or something i
don't even know what it is exactly are
going to be given a name that actually
is the name of a lot of people
um you know no thank you very much
um but what was actually happening there
and i really will link will link to this
and i really encourage you to go listen
to their to the conversation
um turned out to be you know emerging
from
such a deeper and you know if there was
any racism there at all it's un
it's unverifiable and it's probable
there's no racism there at all
and in fact if you swapped the roles of
the two people
the black man and the white woman in
that incident it would have been just as
easy and maybe even easier
to ascribe racism to what is now the
white woman's position which in this
case was the black man doing what what
he was doing so
all of that was fascinating and again i
highly recommend it and we'll link to it
in the
in the description um but the overall
the overwhelming sense that i had coming
away from listening to it was
that this is what happens when our sense
making apparatus becomes conclusion
driven
um that the conclusion is decided before
data come in before evidence comes in in
the case that it might not be data per
se
before analysis is even possible and
certainly before analysis is tolerated
or allowed
and then if and when data or evidence or
analysis does show up
when it runs counter to the conclusion
that has already been generated that is
already foregone
it's ignored and this is not how
journalism is supposed to work
of course or science what it is is pr
it's public relations and it's pr
decked out in the guise of journalism or
science or justice
right but this guy's it has no it has no
clothes you know this is like a classic
emperor has no clothes actually like
look guys that's not journalism
barry weiss being two notable exceptions
in this regard i don't even know if
camille regards himself as a journalist
in general but in this case he did some
extraordinary journalism um
but this this guy's this pr just yells
and yells and yells at us and it can't
see beyond itself and
those who disagree with it are evil or
disgusting
or dirty or deplorable and
of course we're seeing the same thing
over in covet space
the conclusion is foregone we have a
conclusion
there is some conclusion and who knows
under what circumstances and by whom
and for what purposes it is arrived at
but then we are fed
the conclusion along with feel-good
human interest stories
and some of you know something that
looks a little bit like data or
evidence that may or may not be and what
they're effectively doing
is guaranteeing that some
it's increasing a sense of tribe by
dehumanizing those who aren't in tribe
and it pretends that we're all one
people right
it talks a good game about like well
we're all in this together
um but we are actually all one people
and this is doing nothing
to to preserve that and
following along from that i i was
sitting um thinking about the podcast
this morning taking taking some notes
reading a couple of research articles
um in this beautiful park today um and
i was listening i ended up eavesdropping
and i ended up
ultimately going over and and telling
the people that i had been and we had a
wonderful conversation
um i was positioned such that i couldn't
help it over here with these three women
um you know a bit older than us you know
three women
um liberals ian or outside of portland
um white women not that it should matter
um people with adult children because i
heard them talking about them
who were engaging in this very careful
discussion of
of covet in so many ways one of them had
been diagnosed with it and gotten a
false negative first
and then come up with a false positive
but that sent everyone into some kind of
disarray like what do we
you know what are we supposed to do with
this false negative when clearly she
um this person seems to have it um to
which one of the
women sitting there says you know i
don't i just don't think the tests are
reliable and they're not reliable in
either direction there's false negatives
there's false positives
and they're saying that they're not you
know they're not prepared to to travel
yet because
you know it's likely that another um
another wave is coming
um and so and um you know and they're
and they're vaccinated but they're not
they're not sure um
about everything that they're hearing
about the vaccinations and so
one of them said cnn is so untrustworthy
i don't trust them any more than i trust
fox at this point
so again this is liberals and i know a
lot of people um listening to us and
watching us might say
the opposite you know fox is becoming
untrustworthy they don't i don't
trust it anymore that i trust cnn at
this point um
but i'm saying this you know speaking to
um
those many of us who are liberals and
those many
um who would say oh you're not and no
liberals think the way that you do
right this is this is anecdote for sure
um
but listening to these women talk and
then talking with them a little bit
before before i had to leave to come
back to
do this you know they're saying it's
they're talking about particular
politicians and i'm just not going to
name them here and
and you know hollywood actors and stuff
and saying they're trying to make the
unvaccinated enemy it's horrible get
them they seem to be saying
and our country is in such poor shape
and with regard to
um the media and corporation and the
politicians
each of those groups they said they're
just making [ __ ] up
this is what they said over and over
again they're just making [ __ ] up and
the path that we're on 100 for sure
people are going to be restricted in
terms of where they can go
it's terrifying so this is one
conversation
one that i overheard between three women
in
you know very liberal portland very
liberal people
vaccinated who are saying this is
this is a very big problem for our
country and for democracy
and um effectively much like
in a totally different domain what i was
hearing in this conversation with
camille foster and barry weiss on
the honestly pod um that when the
conclusion is handed to you
and you are told there is no possible
other thing that you could conclude
you should immediately begin to wonder
what you're not being told
so um i think you're i think you're on a
very important
topic here and i'm i'm
juggling a few things that seem to fit
together and you know this is the first
time i've heard giriff on this so i
don't know where this goes but
i want to start with um something some
some of our listeners will have heard of
and many will not or won't know what it
means even if they've heard the term
you know what a push poll is i do but uh
so a push-pull is a poll
whose purpose is not to collect
information but actually to drive
belief right um and so and done
by uh you know the the people working on
behalf of politicians like what under
what circumstances do push pulls
exist yeah it's it's often uh done by
workaday people who have just
you know signed up for a job but they're
i think always instituted by
terrible people who are using the act of
data collection
as a stalking horse for another purpose
and it's hard to imagine how any decent
person finds themselves
engaged in that behavior well but i mean
a push poll
i wish we had an example here because my
sense is that they don't always
unless you're unless you're thinking
very carefully they don't necessarily
reveal themselves oh right no they they
it's like any other kind of advertising
right right pr
advertising you're supposed to think
it's not working on you that's when it
works on you right
right um but anyway the idea is there's
something that we all understand to be a
legitimate exercise which is a pole
and because it exists you can use it for
another purpose which is actually to
manipulate people's belief structures
and what you're describing your
conclusion
driven landscape is a place
where the language and form
of logic and analysis is borrowed for
something else
and i think this actually explains a lot
of what is happening it's equivalent to
scientism
right and high x formulation but it's
it's bigger than that yeah it's it's
it's logicism analyticism analyticism
and so here's what i think you and i are
running into
you and i are trying to do an analysis
of an
uh a set of evidence that is nothing if
not
confusing and self-contradictory right
and you know on the one hand that's not
outside of what we do
on topics where there's nothing writing
right in evolutionary biology you're
often looking at
um different kinds of conflicting
evidence and trying to figure out what
the underlying pattern is so you know
that
sorting through evidence and figuring
out what to wait and and
how is a is an art more than a science
and if you're good at it when it comes
what it results in is predictive power
but anyway the point is
that's just a just a thing that we do
we are now doing it in a realm where
everybody perceives a great deal at
stake and there is a lot at stake
um but what that results in is a lot of
people being hostile to the exercise of
those
tools and availing themselves of the
right to
borrow logic and analysis or the
trappings of them
for the purpose of manipulating and i
think
almost to a person that the people that
we come up against
who we know who we have had positive
histories with who are doing this
imagine that where we are is this
this is no time for analysis right it's
like the person who wants to question
authority in the middle
of trying to you know defeat the machine
gun nest right this is not the time for
that this is chain of command people
this is chain of command business and so
the point is look we all understand the
vaccines
are good and that they are the key to
going where we're going and we all
all of us adults understand that it's a
more complicated story than that
and this is no time to talk about
downsides trade-offs
uh risk uncertainty long-term hazards
any of those things because the point is
we either get over some threshold number
in which case things get better or we
don't and you by trying to deploy your
analysis
in the midst of this battle are getting
in the way of us crossing that threshold
now i will speak only for me though i
would imagine you are in the same spot
i've looked at this puzzle there's no
threshold it's not like we're going
somewhere it's not like some policy is
being
deployed that explains what number we're
shooting for and if we can only get
enough people on board we will actually
be able to relax there's no conceivable
way
that this goes that direction but and if
we were if if
even if there had been a number they're
like that's what we're shooting for 100
it'd be like catch 22. they just keep on
upping the
number of missions i think the thing is
either they're so diluted that they
think there's a number
right and they haven't looked at the
vaccines that they have at their
disposal
and what will happen if you there's no
number there's no number to hit the
vaccines are too leaky and there's too
much of the globe they can't reach so
sorry but that's like that's a
combination of
you know the social landscape is such
that actually there is no number
and we're certain of that but the more
important thing of course
is the actual the facts on the ground
the non-social landscape the biology
is such that um we actually have never
heard because there does not exist
they plan to end them endemic with the
extant
vaccines right and so it's all done by
implication well there are vaccines and
vaccines could be used
to end a pandemic and there's some
number that you have to hit and those
people who
uh you know aren't participating are
counterproductive to that end
so it's all done through implication but
it's never stated for some reason
um but in any case i think this
this neatly explains i hope it's not too
neat but i think it neatly explains the
experience of having people who on an
ordinary day
should see through the failures of our
public health apparatus
just as easily as we do who seem to be
completely blind to any level of failure
that exists there
and the basic point is they are on a
team because they believe that we are in
a
battle that has a coherent end point and
that
anybody who is not you know shouldering
their share of the load is
counterproductive rather than no
sorry that battle doesn't even exist
that's not the battle we're in
right um and so frankly i guess
you know the other term that i think
belongs
in in here is that this is basically a
machiavellian approach
to analysis that effectively is
interesting
because there is loosely
understood to be a coherent public
health endpoint
and it is imagined that the
prescriptions we have been given with
respect to what to do
must point in that direction that there
is a
sidelining of one's own self-skepticism
that is resulting in a kind of certitude
from people who
know better than to have that kind of
certitude about anything that they
believe
right yeah you know who who amongst our
friends
isn't good at the question of you know
where's the weak spot in my own argument
right right these people are typically
good at that and they seem to have just
lost touch with that
that instinct which i take to be um
about a i think demonstratively
demonstrably false belief that we are on
a path
and that there is something useful at
the end of it and that
therefore it is simply time to put it
all aside and pull together
well or um i guess an
alternative way to think about where
people believe we are
is that we are um ascending
you know trying to take out a machine
gun nest that we are in
the fog of war and uh that there is
someone
and they are telling us what needs to be
done and um
and ignoring the chain of command here
will get all of us killed
so stop it already right right and and
you know frankly how do you create the
sense of the fog of war without
the fog of war you have to get people
scared you have to get people back on
their heels you have to get people
um terrorized not just by a virus which
is actually
terrible and horror horrifying but also
terrified of each other you have to
create division between
between human beings such that whenever
you go out you're looking at them going
oh i'll bet
but you're the enemy right right so and
in this so two things one in this milieu
the fact that we can't seem to make the
point that hey actually we're not the
thing that you just portrayed us as
right or wrong we don't believe the
things that have been ascribed to us
that's odd that that anybody would be
continuing anybody honorable would be
continuing to assert these things or to
believe them
unless the point was really the purpose
is to get you to stop what you're doing
irrespective true false whatever
right the thing you point to though
about
um it's it's funny this uh
the fog of war is a natural fact of the
confusion of the battlefield and it has
impacts yeah if you need the fog of war
to be useful to some objective that is
unstated and i'm not claiming that
that's what our friends are up to
but i do believe that somebody is sure
uh polluting our environment so that we
are not capable of making sense that we
would otherwise make
it is the fog machine of war
the fog machine the fog machine oh boy
pr meets war yeah yeah
yeah and so that that is in fact what i
think we are really fighting over is
whether or not
this is simply a war and that fog is
natural and we need to get unconfused
and all pull in the same direction or
we are being fogged so that we will be
confused about what is and is not on the
table in terms of
paths forward so that for example the
possibility of driving
sars kobe 2 to extinction which you and
i are still advocating and still i hear
almost nobody else talking about is even
no to the degree that most people say
anything about they say yeah
everything else may be but certainly not
that we're never going to accomplish it
at this point
right even though it seems to be implied
in
the um simplistic prescription that has
been handed to us right what then is
yeah right what then what then are we
trying to achieve right
um so all right fog machine award is
i like it i mean i hate it and i like it
yeah
it's a decent it's clearly horrible it's
clarifying yes yeah
all right um oh so i hadn't yet
talked about what it is that uh we all
are doing that's right and
this is something um i'm just gonna
invite everybody in the sound of
within the sound of our voices to figure
out their own version of this
and join us in it i will say
heather is in a slightly different
position than the rest of our family
because as
many of you will know heather was in a
nearly fatal boat accident what is it
five years ago
um yeah five years nearly five years ago
which means that um
cycling although over five years over
five years
um that bicycling uh which was a major
part of all of our activity
is something heather is working her way
back into but doesn't
isn't where the rest of the family is
exactly at the moment i was thrilled i
mean i just didn't jump here you know
i've been paddle boarding a lot as
as people know but um i and it's
wonderful to be on the water especially
early in the morning
you had some nature but there's no speed
and i love speed
and i did go i did go on a 24 um
mile bike ride yesterday um which was
mostly up and then
mostly down and man i just love going
fast there
there is speed in paddleboarding just so
little it's barely perceptible
all right it's not that i'm staying in
the same place the whole time which
would be its own kind of work but um
yeah yeah no it's it's wonderful but
it's uh you know and just just as
um you know like single track mountain
biking which we used to do a lot of is
fabulous but not when you're out there
as a as a birder
as a naturalist right like you just you
don't see anything you go too fast and
you don't see the nature
so paddle boarding allows you access to
um
to the nature allows you to be a
naturalist at the same time but if you
also
like to both get your heart pumping and
just have the sense of like the world
going
fast past you fast um
bikes are more likely to get you there
so that's true that's true i have been
biking to a nature area and then hanging
out there yeah no that works yeah
you bike there and then you slow down
and then you bike home yeah exactly
but anyway what we are doing is we are
looking at the calendar
and thinking oh god it's going to be
winter here sooner than we know
some of us are thinking if i just write
it down it'll be july it'll be july
i hope that works and please invite us
backwards in time to july i wouldn't
mind that but
yeah um but anyway what uh for two
different reasons one
because of all the things we've talked
about with covid and the
value of being in good health with
respect to fending off
the disease from the point of view of
contracting it and if you do contracting
and having a less severe course of
disease
it makes sense to get into shape while
the sun shines
and the hard part for all of us who live
fairly far
north or presumably fairly far south the
harshness of winter makes it hard to
stay on your
exercise regimen so just simply getting
on your bike
uh here in august is pretty easy because
you don't need to bring that much you
don't need to think about
the exact temperature and all of that
and it's very different
in you know let's say december so we
have set a goal
um in the house and i'm i'm uh going to
be
leading my kids in this um the goal is
kids at this point being 17 and 15 year
old really oh yes
young man right um we are going to ride
a century that is a hundred miles in one
go before it's too cold to do it which
really means before school
starts um i mean those are two different
goals oh yeah
you might you might want to clarify
exactly which goal it is because
well i'm i'm talking especially here
summer tends to you know our summer
weather often lasts through mid-october
yeah i'm it's not it's not the necessity
i mean the days do get shorter which
makes it more challenging too
because there are fewer hours of
daylight but um but anyway we're going
to ride 100 miles
and we're going to try to do that before
school starts if it ends up being after
school starts that's not a big deal but
before it becomes
a matter of needing equipment to stay
warm and all of that we're going to
ride 100 miles which is obviously not a
huge number people ride hundreds of
miles
all the time i've done it many times i
haven't done it in
quite a number of years but anyway it's
a challenge you definitely feel it it's
not the kind of thing you can just hop
on a bike and do you have to train a
little bit to get there
but the idea is at the beginning of
cooler weather
you get to the point that your body can
do the 100-mile ride
and then as the weather warms up on the
other side of winter
you get to that point again as quickly
as possible and you use it kind of
as a bookend and the idea is the amount
of
fitness you lose over the winter as it
becomes harder to ride a long distance
without
getting cold and soaked or whatever um
you know
you lose less and you stay in better
condition and then that will have
coveted benefits too
so that's the plan um and uh
i'm i'm hoping you will end up uh making
that goal
but it's obviously not um you know
you're doing other things that we're not
doing so yeah i'm not setting it as a
goal but um i will participate for
instance we're going to do a 40
40 ish mile ride next weekend plan and
um i will participate
with you guys in that and um and i guess
you wanted to
you know not yet formally but maybe talk
about at some point formally inviting
uh people to uh to
to have their own challenges to join i
think i think this year
as we're rapidly ramping up to
uh this year's century it's not going to
work for us to gather with others here
uh locally but on the other side of
winter
i'd be kind of interested in seeing if
there are enough people in the portland
area that we could uh you know hold each
other's feet to the fire a little bit
do people bike in portland or people do
bike in portland
yeah they do yeah quite quite a number
of them um so anyway
uh you know if you're not in portland or
even if you are
we would encourage you to do something
in the
waning days of summer to
gain as much fitness and as much vitamin
d as you can
and um to think about uh
how you're going to return to that state
of fitness at the far end of
of the cold season yeah and figure out i
mean just like with food
you know some people are like well you
know i don't want to eat healthy because
it doesn't taste good to me and
yeah good delicious delicious
we eat very very healthy and yeah we
also eat you know we also eat we
do have some sugar and some alcohol and
stuff in our in our diets
um but it's delicious we eat
extraordinarily well
and it's you know from the farmers
markets and from um you know from
farm-raised grass-fed beef and you know
these these sorts of things and it's
fabulous and so you do have to train
your palate if you were raised on other
stuff or if you become accustomed to
other stuff
and the same thing with exercise you
know if your sense of what you have to
do to be in shape
is you know if if what i had to do to be
in shape was go inside in a gym
and do repetitive stuff on machines i
wouldn't i just wouldn't i can't i
cannot imagine that and for some people
that's terrific
for me and i think i've actually
mentioned this on the show before um i
like
you know part of what i get from being
outside is the is the constantly
changing conditions and the slight risk
frankly
um of just being somewhere where you got
you got a little skin in the game
um in terms of taking on some risk um
because you are outside and then that
also means that you get you know you can
be surprised like i saw
a couple what a week ago some i saw mink
uh while i was paddle boarding um you
know bouncing along going you know it
came out of the water then it was in the
rocks going out it would stop and look
at me and i got pretty close
um and i watched oh my god i think maybe
i mentioned this already but i watched
this
this eagle uh diving for ducks
uh bald eagle not a not an osprey which
you tell me is an eagle as well
um so you just you see things that are
unexpected
and that itself can take you into new
places in your head
and take you out of whatever stuck
places you were in
and so you know it's not just about the
physical fitness part of it so you'll
figure out what it is
for you that's gonna that you want to do
that you will find pleasurable
and you know to get your your yayas out
right and
not to say that as much as you know we
used to bike a lot
and still um in the various places where
we bite and we would
we did a lot of single track mountain
biking it was really hard to get that
activation energy to get out the door
even though we loved
we not only loved having done it which
is fairly common but we loved actually
doing it
and yet still the motivation to actually
get out there i had the same experience
yesterday it's like i don't want to go
i'm a bit of a bike in a while
and i just had a fabulous time yeah so
um
you know it it is true that your brain
can convince you that whatever it is
that you're not yet doing is just too
hard and it's better off for you to
sit on the couch with your with your
cheetos but um
but really overcome the inertia and make
the inertia work for you such that
you're once you're moving
then you're more likely to stay moving
yeah
and i think you know one one of the
rules has got to be
figure out what works for you right and
you know
uh there are lots of options available
we don't have any electric bikes um but
electric bikes
open up a world of possibilities and
it's strikes true too
yeah trikes are complex to get anywhere
unfortunately
um but um you know electric bike you can
go a lot farther with the same input of
energy it's not necessarily like you're
working less hard it's just you know how
far do you want to get with it
um uh you know i have a
a helmet that i use to listen to music
if i'm
you know biking somewhere that's not
super interesting to look at and you
don't find that helmet to be one of the
horsemen of the apocalypse
no it's actually no i find it
it's great because well what it does is
it uh
you the music is a close enough to your
ears
that it's not loud to other people b
it's not in an earbud that blocks your
hearing of things in traffic that you
need to be aware of
um it's easy to silence it if you need
to
you can also you know if i'm late coming
home as you know i can call you or text
you
from the helmet and you know anyway
it's not the most natural experience but
i do find
uh you know it means that i get out on
the bike more because i can
multitask a little bit or whatever you
can yeah you actually do phone calls
from it um whereas i um
i really relish the the silence um
as you know the one the you got me one
of these and you tried hooking it up and
it lasted about 15 seconds it's like
it's the helmet
or the marriage really oh god i didn't
know it was that bad
it wasn't that was that was an
exaggeration thank you for choosing the
marriage
yeah i mean i still have the helmet it's
just not activated yeah
okay as far as i know
it needs a vpn
all right good are we there i think
we're there okay um so
uh as as has become our our want
we are working through the chapters of
our book in the weeks before publication
so 13 chapters all told and we are now
on chapter 8 parenthood and relationship
so there's a lot in here so last week's
last week's
chapter was sex and gender and we talked
a bit there about mating systems there's
a lot in this chapter about manning
systems that's not where we're going to
go today
um i will say as a little teaser um the
my natural selections post next tuesday
is about polyandry
um so for that so yep yep you didn't
know that but uh
is that a threat no it's not okay yeah
you should read it you should subscribe
i do subscribe no um so um
so we we will we will we have and we
will continue to talk about mating
systems which just
means um the terms you'll be familiar
with are like monogamy and polygamy
um and the promiscuous mating system
which in humans is
often called polyamory but you know
descriptive
of on average how many partners do
individuals of one sex tend to have
versus the other um so um we talk about
that a lot in the book but we're not
that's not the section we're going to
read from today can i ask you one
question before you move on to the
the reading absolutely have you tried if
you said
no i have not you know that thank you um
have you tried the um term
you say promiscuity goes by the name
polyamory in
modern circles i have the sense of every
polyamorous person
within earshot of this podcast their
blood pressure going up sure you say
that
yeah um and you know i can yeah it's not
quite right
right it's not quite right it's it's not
quite right um
and so there is no you know polyamory
is a moder is a is a modern weird
capitals
you know acronym weird uh human thing
that i don't think has a representation
in non-human animals or even
in sort of pre-industrial cultures um
and so you know promiscuity as a mating
system
in which there really is no um
there is no sticking to any particular
mate and so individuals of both sexes
might have one or two or eight or 40
partners whatever
whereas polyamory is having you know
having a primary partner but also having
sexual relationships with other people
in a in a mutually agreed upon
um situation it's not cheating it's um
it's disgust and uh
past tense of disgust right so um i also
uh should say i've had extensive
discussions on this topic with a number
of people that we know
who are polyamorous and um
one person in particular who i think i'm
not going to name because i don't know
uh whether he would i don't think he's
secretive about it but in any case um
one person did manage to convince me
that there is sort of
a higher order pattern that effectively
people who are serious about polyamory
are actually serious about
stabilizing something that is not in any
way
uh indiscriminate and so
right but as i remember this set of
conversations
uh it requires a stability over enough
generations
right right and um if you're if you're
the rare phenotype if the rare mating
system phenotype
um in this chaotic culture um we're
never going to get there well
right two things i would say one he
convinced me
that such a stable structure is
at least possible that it did require
the demonstrations of it
require a
long-term multi-generation process of
discovery of what the stable pattern was
and i also say that i will say
i have particular concerns that um
the real fly in the ointment is that the
raising of children
yeah maybe uh even in those stable
patterns
not so easily done well because of
course
humans are so thoroughly wired for
investing in their own
children that you know there's a there's
a there's a hazard to kids
involved in uh those things and i so i
feel
quite differently about um people's
exploring this if no kids are involved
right that is you know it stands to do
less harm
than if kids are uh caught up in the in
the mix
indeed agreed i'm i'm glad it went there
and i don't have to
threaten to investigate polyandry we're
thoroughly this is not going well
it's going just fine okay okay so um
we're gonna read just a couple of
short sections from the end of
parenthood and relationship which is
chapter eight of
hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
um having just so the section
immediately proceeding
is a fairly um a fairly
in-depth and discussion of senescence
and um and and how our children provide
us
immortality of sorts which is fairly
fairly deep and serious section so love
across species
in pursuing lighter fare than
considering that children not
immortality are the antidote to aging
let us ask we love our pets but do they
love us
humans have domesticated dozens of
species of animals across the globe
mostly to provide food or do labor for
us some of those relationships that
began as purely functional
cats as mousers dogs as protection have
since become cross species friendships
cats have befriended us for far less
time and remain more wild than dogs
more of their original selves although
they bond tightly to humans under the
right circumstances
even before we began to farm though dogs
were by many of our sides becoming
domesticated
as hunter-gatherers some of us already
had dog friends
dogs are in many way a human construct
we have co-evolved with them for so long
that they are now attuned to human
behavior
language and emotion perhaps you could
argue then
that humans are also partially a canine
construct
does your pet love you of course your
pet loves you
qualifier your pet can love you if it's
a mammal or one of a few clades of birds
like a parrot
if your pet is a gecko or a python or a
goldfish your pet is probably incapable
of love
love develops for every evolutionary
pairing that requires devotion
we love our pets and our pets love us
dogs in particular are love generators
who hang out with you and help you know
that you're not alone
dog is love unmoored
watch how cats and dogs engage with each
other and with us they don't use
language to convey meaning and emotion
but convey it they do
you have no reason to doubt that your
dog is disappointed when you stop
throwing the ball for him
or that your cat would prefer that you
stay seated with her in your lap
we name our emotions love fear grief
and when we attribute those words to
animals we may be accused of
anthropomorphizing
as franz duvall who has spent a lifetime
studying emotion and animals points out
this argument is rooted in assumptions
of humans being not just exceptional
but wholly different from the other
animals with which we share ancestors
we need to be careful in how we
attribute emotion and attention to other
animals
as we should within our own species as
well but there can be no doubt that many
other species plan and grieve
love and reflect in our interactions
with our pets we read their cues without
language
it is helpful too in your interactions
with people to turn the sound down
sometimes
be an animal behaviorist or just act
sometimes like a human before language
evolved
we often use language to cover how we
actually feel to deceive
to throw off the scent of what is
actually going on when you watch people
especially strangers from a distance
it's relatively easy to read the emotion
of the situation
pay attention to people's behavior not
the stories that people tell about their
behavior
that's what your dog is doing your dog
doesn't buy your cover story
although he is likely to forgive you for
your foibles
next section grief in his metamorphoses
avid writes of the old married couple
bacchus and philemon
they have been poor all of their lives
but generous with what little they have
the gods recognize them for their
righteousness and ask what they would
like most in the world
bacchus and philemon ask that when death
draws near they might die together so
that neither shall see the other die nor
be left behind
the gods make it so the old lovers
become trees an oak and a linden
which intertwine their branches with one
another as they grow
absent interference from zeus the only
way to avoid grief is to live a life
without love
grief has evolved multiple times across
species always in highly social
organisms with parental care
the grief of chimps is presumably the
same at its root as human grief
the grief of dogs has distinct origins
though as the most recent common
ancestor that we share with dogs
was a nondescript little mammal with
little to no social structure
perhaps the most famous story of how
grief manifests in dogs is that of
hachiko
a handsome akita who was born in japan
in 1923.
hachiko was taken in by hirasaburo ueno
a professor of agriculture who commuted
to work by train
every day when ueno was due back hachiko
met him at the train station and they
walked home together
one day awana did not return having died
of a cerebral hemorrhage while lecturing
hachiko however continued to go to the
train station every day
and wait for his master for nearly 10
years until he himself died
the grief of canids wolves and domestic
dogs evolved separately from our own
elephants also grieve as do killer
whales in all of these cases grief is
independently evolved yet deeply similar
an extreme emotional response to the
death of an intimate unpredictable in
its length and manifestation
modern approaches to loss into grief
tend to over-emphasize metrics and
logistics
how many years had he been sick how do i
obtain a death certificate close bank
accounts cancel appointments
and spend too little on meaning a
narrative what did he bring to us how
are we better for him having lived
we often don't want to see the body or
sit with it at all death is it to remove
in this particular hyper-novel situation
in which it is our choice to not
confront the corpse of a loved one can
render us more confused in the aftermath
of death
grief is us recalibrating our brains for
a world without one of its central
pieces
we must reformulate our understanding as
we are no longer able to go to that
person or animal
for words of wisdom or comfort but we
are still able to think back
to learn from and to take comfort in the
relationship that can no longer grow but
can still be remembered
we don't want to believe in their
permanent absence and so our brains
create fictions
ghosts was that him turning the corner
at the cafe we used to frequent
surely that was her i know her hair her
jacket getting on the train
grief is the downside of high bandwidth
interdependence
grief is the downside of love all too
often moderns try to protect children
from grief
for instance we have known parents who
would not allow their children to attend
their grandparents funerals for fear
that it would scare them or harm them
this fear and anxiousness in raising
children in turn creates fearful and
anxious children
in the next chapter we explore childhood
and how to raise children who are
independent
exploratory and full of love
and then the very first corrective lens
for this chapter is
now actually the second one spend time
with the body of your loved one after
they die
those who have lost loved ones to
situations from which their bodies could
not be recovered
often suffer from prolonged periods of
grief
when we view our dead sit with them and
talk with them we set a foundation upon
which our grief our natural
recalibration
can be moored
so i mean this this chapter goes has a
ton of stuff in it right it's all over
the place
um but that felt that felt appropriate
given that we recently lost one of our
one of our kitties
moxie as regular viewers and listeners
now
um and of course that hadn't happened at
the point that we were writing this
but i was i was thinking specifically of
of my father and of your grandfather um
who had you know who who had died within
a decade um of of writing this
uh and just thinking about
the way that the modern medical
structure moved in and tried to
uh prevent the natural grieving process
in both
in both cases right in the case of my
father
um who unfortunately died in the icu
um but surrounded by five people in the
world who who loved him tremendously
uh my mother his wife um
and you know who they would have just
celebrated their 53rd
wedding anniversary this last month uh
and you and i
are two children um and the
staff at the hospital and the you know
the staff at the hospital were mostly
quite kind
and understanding but they were um i
think shocked
that we wanted to stay in the room
afterwards and we stayed with his body
for an
hour or so
and then also accompanied it
to the crematorium when when it came
time for that and
it it really helped
assure me anyway of what i did not want
to be true
but it assured me that it was true and
it helped me not
be in denial about it any more than
would have been would have been helpful
yeah the ambiguity that one is left with
if
one doesn't have some sort of evidence
that's incontrovertible
is obviously a source of um
of danger psychologically speaking yeah
and
uh it is not surprising that we would be
built this way
because you know to put it in relatively
stark terms
a human being is a big animal and
it's hard for a human being to die in
um you know your home range and
there to be no evidence so in general
our ancestors would have had a pretty
good idea
you know somebody wouldn't simply
disappear with no sign
there'd be uh awareness in general
um and so lost at c is particularly hard
for this reason right well and
c is novel that's the thing it's not
that novel but
uh yeah we were coastline explorers for
a long time but not deep
deep ocean voyagers until relatively
recently right and i'm not saying it
never happened and i'm not saying that
the evidence was always
um you know uh really substantial
obviously there are predators in the
world but a predator doesn't tend to
take out a human being and leave no
evidence and
you know there tends to be uh a record
enough that a person can grieve and move
on which
we argue is you know is this is the
downside of love it's not that grief is
inherently
good but grief is necessary when you
have loved a person or
a creature deeply in order to rewire
so that um their absence is not a
constant
obstacle to functioning same thing as
you know just as we were talking about
earlier today
anxiety and depression are not
inherently maladaptive
right you know some sometimes the world
is such that depression is the
appropriate response
sometimes your situation is such that
anxiety is the appropriate response
you know when someone you love has has
died grief is the appropriate response
can each of those appropriate adaptive
responses
occur in situations or for duration for
instance
that make them maladaptive of course and
um you know but but
the modern quick fix types of solutions
would have you medicate equally all
instantiations
and that that misunderstands
um that there are there are appropriate
times and places for
for all of these responses of course and
in fact the
um the pattern of grief leaves no doubt
whatsoever this is not a malfunction
right this is a highly organized process
which tells you that
you know it is it is providing a benefit
um and i would say it's a necessity
um you know and it's one of these things
one of the one of the things
features of the pattern is that you can
put off grief
right if you can't you you don't grieve
on the battlefield when your best friend
has just died in front of you you fight
and then you grieve later
and that that capacity to put it off um
but not
forever is you know one of its
fascinating features and of course
you would expect that you can't have a
creature who can be suddenly debilitated
by grief so that they themselves succumb
to whatever the threat is that just
wouldn't make sense as a program
so so it isn't like that
but it is also true that we
intervene in this process you know both
by
um you know removing bodies and having a
process that deals with them
so that you know the family doesn't have
contact that might
be part of the closure process but we
also
i think this we did not put this into
the the book but
there's this issue of you know
in our case we did not
ask to know the sex of the
children that we were going to have in
one case we found out accidentally
because the technician
uh you know it was pretty rare we
specifically asked not to
we asked not to know explicitly yeah i
know i took it out of the book because
it was
i don't know we didn't have time to
explore it fully but i will just say
that the
the question is this yeah no it is it's
gone i think it's not there
um but the question is is this
if you are going to have a child and you
do not know
its sex in advance as no ancestor until
very recently could have been certain
what it does is it prevents you from
doing too much scenario building about
what your life is going to look like
after the child is born
and what that means is that the degree
to which you have to forget
this lesson is um
decreased and that in some sense by now
providing this information which seems
like what could the harm
of more information about you know the
child you're going to have
what could the harm of that possibly be
well the harm could be that once you
know you're going to have a boy or
you're going to have a girl and you
start thinking about
here are the places we'll go this is
what we'll do this is what it'll be like
that there is the need for vastly more
grief to unwire those things
at the point of loss well i guess i mean
i would also
argue that um you know for us
we intended to raise our children
without the expectation of of
stereotypes
right um and we're not gonna paint a
room blue or pink depending on the sex
of the child
um either way right that was just never
never in anything that we were thinking
and um
frankly imagining all the possibilities
absent any overlay
of of of boy or girl male or female
helped helped keep that alive and you
know even though i think that we were
particularly just because of who we are
and how we think and what we think about
would have been unlikely to fall prey to
those kinds of stereotypes but
especially in this
in this modern era um
where we should be as free as possible
from
the traditional gender roles that don't
have specific anatomical or
physiological bases
um you know what what does it get you
to know in advance if you're going to
have a boy or a girl and you know in
both cases because i was
um because i was older um you know we
had all the genetic testing and so you
know we there was a karyotype and a
sealed envelope in both cases that you
know i could have looked at it any
moment yep
since looked at and like sure enough
sure enough that y chromosome in both
cases but
um specifically did not want to know in
advance
yeah um and you know at some level even
if you didn't
have um these two reasons formulated
that you might not want to know the one
thing that you can know for sure
is that the information wouldn't have
been available to an ancestor and so you
don't know whether there's any
you know harm downstream of it now of
course
scientifically speaking this makes a
prediction which is that in the case
that somebody
loses uh a pregnancy
that the amount of grief will actually
correlate with
um whether or not they did or didn't
know
and that at some level is something i
think we should be i don't know if it's
been tested but
it is something we should be looking
into because at some level
um the the the natural way of doing this
may simply be
superior and we may be creating
unnatural trauma
um that could you know be avoided if we
just simply realized we were being
unwise
yeah you know i actually remember um a
grad school colleague
now this one in the 90s i think or maybe
early very early odds
um who uh he was
a guy but we were also friends with his
uh with his wife who was also a grad
school colleague and
and she got pregnant um and she never
said this
um but he said at the point that they
revealed what the sex of their baby was
gonna be i don't even remember what it
was
um and i said something to him like
are you sure that that's something that
you wanted to know or i don't know
exactly what i said he said
i'm a scientist more information is
always better
i thought that seems like a rule
that sounds like something you can say
and have most people agree with
but i don't think it's true yeah it's
definitely not it's not true
there are many cases in which more
information tends to be better but there
are certainly cases where more
information can
be destructive yeah exactly
um okay should we um should we talk a
little bit about breastfeeding
of course of course so um this will seem
like a totally different thing um the
final corrective lens
of this chapter is actually about it and
i wasn't going to talk about it but then
i was
i was reading the new york times i don't
know i know i was reading the new york
times the sunday paper and
we still get it we still get it in hard
copy last week
august 1st and i came across this full
page ad which i'm just going to show you
briefly i'm going to read
it okay so this yeah how is
breastfeeding going it says except
breast is crossed out
it's crossed out and then it's got four
uh testimonials
brief one word testimonials um someone
named leslieanne says don't assume my
breasts can make milk
uh someone who is a
tan france i guess a gay man says don't
assume i want to feed my baby donut
breast milk
an entrepreneur and hannah says don't
assume i can do it all
and a philanthropist named kelly says
don't assume breast was best for my
entire family
the rest of the ad reads nearly 75 of us
parents will turn to formula within the
first six months
so why are we ashamed to talk about it
it's time to evolve the conversation
we'll start so i obviously pulled this
from the paper and saved it
and i then went to the site
being somewhat horrified by this
full-page ad in the front section of the
new york times
and i find this this is how is feeding
going dot com
we're starting a movement it's time to
evolve the conversation around how we
feed our babies make the commitment
and it says i commit to evolving the
conversation around how we feed our
babies by asking a new question how is
feeding
going your commitment will further help
bobby shake the stigma on formula
feeding every committed voice
helps reduce another parent's guilt
so you can take my screen off here first
of all guilt
like anxiety like depression like grief
is appropriate in some circumstances and
not in others
same thing with stigma some stigmas
exist for a good reason
uh it turns out that it's an entire
thing and i'm going to try not to swear
here
even though i don't always try not to
swear um it's a it's a formula company
of course this is an advertisement the
whole thing is a
is an advertisement for formula company
and it's reprehensible and
confused and unlike your helmet another
horseman of the apocalypse
and it comes in this like woman-friendly
family-friendly guys it's a couple of
women who
really felt that they needed to create
this formula company but it's
manipulative and greed driven
and yes i think another existential
threat
so i'm gonna just i'm gonna read this
last corrective lens for this chapter
and then um go to one of the papers so
when i'm reading excerpts i'm not
reading the footnotes obviously but this
book is very well referenced we've got
a lot of primary literature and other
literature in it i'm going to go to one
of the papers that this corrective lens
paper cites
this corrective lens bullet point at the
end of our chapter
sites breastfeed your infants if you can
adults who are breastfed have better
formed palates and better aligned teeth
compared to those who are bottle-fed
and breast milk has in it all manner of
nutrients and information that we do not
understand
it may for instance contain cues with
which the infant entrains his sleep wake
cycle
thus if you do breastfeed and also punk
milk to feed the babies at other times
feeding your baby milk that was pumped
at the same time of day as it currently
is
could be helpful in getting your baby to
sleep when you want him to
put another way beware chesterton's
breast milk
so before we go to the literature i just
want to say with regard to that
that hypothesis in the second half here
the idea that
there may actually be like circadian
cues in the breast milk which may help
in train the sleep wake cycle of the
baby
is a hypothesis put forth by a former
student of ours josie jarvis
um and i actually approached her when
when writing this and said you know have
you
ever published anything you have
anything and um um you know i have what
we have is the paper that she wrote for
us
uh in the program in which she um you
know described
a considerable amount of evidence in
support of the hypothesis but still
you know not directly tested uh but you
know it's
it just it points again to the idea that
um simply you know if you really do
recognize and you know believe and
recognize
the facts that breast milk is best for
your child
through some some age and what age that
is varies widely between cultures
then it is and therefore you are
interested in pumping milk
um in order to give your child that milk
when you can't be there for
for him or her um it actually makes
sense and we hadn't thought about this
um so this was not something that we did
for our own children but um to actually
keep track of the time of day when you
express the milk because
sending sending a child who wakes the
middle of the night if it's your partner
who's getting up to feed them for
instance
um giving the milk that was expressed
midday may in fact wake the child up
more and
again this is a hypothesis that has not
been tested but um
they're given how much immunological
endocrinological
stuff material there is in breast milk
it almost seems to me once josie
proposed this to us i felt like oh
it's like so many of the best
evolutionary hypotheses um
obvious in retrospect which was almost
the name of our book right obvious in
retrospect highly
highly likely to be true and um
you know and also this is the
this is the perfect demonstration that
it's not like
a paleo everything right right there is
a role
for pumping breast milk and modern
society and
the way we relate to work makes it
useful but the point is there's a
there's a ham-fisted way of doing it in
which you assume that this
all this is is food right and then
there's a way that understands that
actually this is a
complex mechanism through which mothers
have been communicating with babies in a
way neither of them understands
for i guess almost 100
million years no not quite but
nonetheless i mean it's a minute i
missed the oh mammals yeah
mammals is is probably closer to 200
million 200 million
all right yeah well well older than
chixolab impact
um but you know 100 right 200 million
100 to 200 million
okay so in any case the um
the point is this is a this is a complex
phenomenon and
you know is there room to disturb it
yeah you may even have to disturb it and
not everybody can breastfeed but the
idea that we're going to pretend that
breastfeeding that
promoting breastfeeding is a bad thing
because
it's insensitive to somebody who can't
do it that's true
and the fact that a majority of of
mothers currently feed their
kids some formula and therefore we need
to normalize it and destigmatize
it that's no argument it's not that's no
argument at all
right it's it's it's quite appalling and
the the issue of
palette actually yeah i want to return
to that one and so this actually
let me just uh let me just read the
introduction of this paper because this
is actually the paper about
um palette um this is by actually a
dentist at dds
uh brian palmer from 1998 called the
influence of breastfeeding on the
development of the oral cavity a
commentary
so the short introduction simply reads
and you can show my screen if you want
sakura you don't have to
conventional wisdom supported by
scientific research advocates
breastfeeding as the superior method of
infant feeding
the nutritional immunological
psychological and general health
advantages conveyed to infants have been
documented for years and then he has
nine
citations lugovich listed the merits of
human breast milk as compared to
artificial feeds to include ideal
nutritional content
better absorption fewer food-related
allergies more favorable psychological
development
better immunologic defenses and a
substantial economic advantage
there is another compelling benefit to
exclusive breastfeeding positive effects
on the development of an infant's oral
cavity including improved shaping of the
hard palate resulting in proper
alignment of teeth
and fewer problems with male occlusions
the purpose of this commentary is to
stimulate further research as well
as to propose the importance of
breastfeeding to developing and
maintaining the physiologic integrity of
the oral cavity
and then he's just got a ton of evidence
in here about and you know including
from
historic um for basically skull
collections from
both modern and historic peoples and
you know yes some of that's going to be
diet as we've talked about before as you
talked about with mike mu
in summer of 2020 but
the idea here is that in part um
basically the
the way that the tongue and the jaw are
held
during breastfeeding as opposed to with
an artificial nipple are so different
that you end up with things
like tongue thrust in bottle-fed kids
and that you don't
in in breastfed kids and that those
things those misalignments those male
occlusions
tongue thrusts and such persistent to
adulthood
right um and result in a tremendous
amount of orthodontia which is it's
self-destructive as i
uh learned all too painfully um but
anyway the to connect this up with the
mic mu
stuff right mike does a great job
of laying out the evidence that suggests
that all of this tooth alignment stuff
is likely to be downstream of changes in
diet
and you know behavior and not the result
as the entire field
of orthodontia of orthodontist has it
that it's some sort of
mystical mysterious uh failure of genes
which couldn't possibly be the answer
our genes just got
really bad really bad really quick and
the point is the evidence from
other creatures from ancestral uh
populations all suggest something very
different and you know that it isn't one
thing you know you've got breastfeeding
you've got uh
you know the chewing the gnawing on
harder foods by very young children
early on
which is good for jaw development good
for jaw development
and the point is it results in a
a mouth shape that is proper and
prevents all of these other things it's
not just your teeth alignment it's you
know whether or not you have things like
sleep apnea
and exactly nasal cavity development
even i think
is some evidence for soft tissue in the
esophagus development
right so anyway it just it's the same
story again and again we have some
foolish simplistic medical explanation
for why there's so much dysfunction in
the world when really the answer is
many many variations on the same theme
which is somewhere along the line we
disrupted something
that was important that we didn't
understand the function of
and we never got around to saying hey
maybe that was a mistake
right and so this is you're watching
that mistake
be amplified with sophisticated
advertising
with a full-page ad in the new york
times and you know that's not to say
it's not an appropriate remedy if you
can't
breastfeed your child but breastfeeding
is simply superior and i mean i think
one of the errors here is and i i guess
i alluded to this already is
um excuse me the idea that if if
something has been stigmatized
we as fully sophisticated modern people
should recognize that that's regressive
and archaic and we need to abolish the
stigma
and no right like some things that have
been stigmatized should still be
stigmatized
to use the example i gave last week
pedophilia like
that needs to remain stigmatized and you
know
all of it all of the horrible things
that i could list here right like
they need they need to stay stigmatized
rape and incest and murder and like
these things need to stay stigmatized
and the idea therefore that something
uh that was stigmatized needs to come
out into into the light like it's it's a
borrowing
of the successes of civil rights frankly
and women's rights
and we're seeing it across the board you
know the the idea that
um we lived in a in a
much more racist society in the past and
uh
most of us have seen the areas of our
ways and so have we society-wide
and we can therefore look back on that
and see how bad it was
well now people are taking that overlay
and applying it to things to which it
does not belong
yeah another way to say this
is that many things like stigma are
named
after the malignant version of something
functional
and so we tend to get the sense that
everything that looks like that is
bad when in fact no there's a category
where you've got some adaptive you know
guilt for example
right right guilt has a bad rap but it
shouldn't
right guilt is one of the things that
causes us to self-regulate
and there's a point at which you're
feeling too much guilt to be adaptive
where it becomes maladaptive at which
point we start noticing it
and that's not the way it should work so
if we can divide
you know all of these things into
to what degree has it been useful to
what degree was it adaptive to what
degree is it still adaptive
and when have you gone beyond what is
adaptive when is it
a pathological version of the thing um
it's a much
it's a much healthier way of viewing it
rather than you know stigma bad
right it's a it's a very binary approach
to the world yep
all right are we there i believe we are
all right
um we're going to take for those of you
listening we will be back here next week
uh for episode 92 and for those of you
watching
if you care to stick around we're going
to take a 15-minute break ish then be
back with a live q a your questions
uh can be asked at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
um we don't get to all of them we pick
and choose
we prioritize on some bases but we look
forward to seeing what you're asking
please consider joining our patreons as
as we said before
uh we have a monthly private q a at mine
and brett has
uh more intimate conversations yet on
his
uh you can get some merchandise goliath
shirts darkhorse shirts
at store.darkhorsepodcast.org email
logistical questions
like uh where can i send a thing we've
been getting some some lovely
gratitude in the mail lately and end
some gifts as well
for which we are very very grateful um
and if you want to know
where you could send such things you can
email or how to use the q
a system or anything else email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
and consider subscribing to all four yes
four of all
of our channels the two on youtube and
the two on odyssey
that's brett weinstein's main channel on
both and the darkhorse podcast clips
anything to say before i finish our sign
off uh
no but yeah figure out a an exercise
regimen and get to it because winter is
coming
be good to the ones you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you